hey youtubers it's Charlie since the
Olympics is going on there's no new
agents of shield I wanted to do a fun
bonus video and the biggest mystery
right now is the identity of the
clairvoyant so I wanted to float a fun
theory to you that it is all a giant
fake out and there is no clairvoyant
it's really low-key I do have a couple
alternative theories that are a little
more realistic and tie into the plot of
Winter Soldier and age of Ultron but
let's have some fun with this
so here's five big reasons that the
clairvoyant is really just Loki number
five Tom Hiddleston has always wanted to
participate in shield since Joss Whedon
announced it back in August Tom
Hiddleston said he would love to play a
role and even talk to Joss Whedon about
it but like all great actors he is way
too busy for an extended run on a TV
show plus there's the Edit fact that
he'd totally steal any scene he was in
making things really confusing for the
writers and the audience that does not
mean that he could not totally do a very
brief cameo in a kind of classic villain
revealed during the finale using him
would be a really easy way for the show
nurse to answer a lot of fans complaints
about the show not tying in with the
movies enough number four since Thor the
dark world Loki has actually been ruling
Asgard as Odin as Guardians have
wonderful toys but the all-father has a
special Observatory that helps him see
things in the way that Heimdall does
this would actually give him the
appearance of clairvoyance even if he
didn't have any special toys you know
regular Asgardian technology would
probably be enough for him to peep on
anyone if he really wanted to number
three he actually does have a little bit
of an axe to grind with Coulson
remembered just before he died in the
Avengers Coulson really shook his
confidence for a minute and then shot
him with a destroyer gun
they never did really explain how that
gun worked loki probably wouldn't be
engineering a super soldier army just to
get back at Coulson he is the god of
mischief so he could just be killing two
birds with one stone number two it would
be a really easy way for them to keep
Tom Hiddleston on screens even though
he's not gonna be in any movies until
Phase three was just still a long ways
off everyone really wants a Loki movie
but Marvel has made no plans to make one
so how do they keep the fandom happy and
save themselves 200 million dollars by
just including him on their TV show
quick sidenote Tom Hiddleston has also
kind of become Marvel's international
ambassador for public events something
he's really happy to do as an actor and
something we were really happy to watch
him do and the number one reason why the
clairvoyant could totally be Loki there
has been so much Asgard this season for
do you have the rage spear from last
year now lady SIF is getting her own
episode each time they keep escalating
the Asgard the next step up that
superhero ladder would be someone major
from the movies and Chris Hemsworth is
shooting Avengers age of Ultron in
England starting this week so he's
definitely not gonna be on the show
which leaves Loki of course and it has
the opportunity to tie up some other
threads like the identity of Skye's
parents she could totally be half as
guardian and why else would her name be
Skye if she did not come from the sky so
all that being said here a couple more
realistic choices that also tie in with
the plot of Winter Soldier and age of
Ultron number one Armin Zola
from Captain America this is actually my
number one alternative theory the
character has actually been the big
villain featured in the Captain America
comic books recently and the actor Toby
Jones teased that he would be coming
back in Winter Soldier as MODOK Marvel's
big comic book stories usually precede
the movies by a couple years so the
timing would line up if MODOK was the
villain in the Captain America comic
books my number two theory is Samuel
Sterns the leader in the prequel comic
books he was actually being kept in the
same facility the tesseract experiments
were being done in he's been a
relatively minor character and Tim Blake
Nelson the actor who played him in
Incredible Hulk would be a lot easier to
get than say someone like Tom Hiddleston
his character is actually so smart that
it could be construed as clairvoyance
and my number 3 theory is the Mandarin
much less likely though if you consider
that Skye was found in China it could be
possible that her father was Chinese I'm
actually expecting her status as 0 84 to
tie in with the clairvoyant so it's
possible that the Mandarin is her real
father that being said a character is
big as the Mandarin being revealed on a
TV show is really unlikely so MODOK and
the leader are much better bets still
crossing my fingers that Loki is the
clairvoyant and Skye's father would that
not be the most badass thing ever in
related news I am posting a bonus arrow
and flash video on Wednesday along with
my Game of Thrones Q&A video be sure to
subscribe to get those they also just
announced several new characters for
Fox's Gotham TV show I'm still waiting
for them to cast the Bruce Wayne
character before I do a video for that
right now click here to learn all about
that new flash TV show and click here to
get my last agents of shield video thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives